[Music]
hey Google let's talk to angular
firebase.com sure here's the test
version of angular firebase.com howdy
partner i'm angular firebase what can I
do you for what's the latest episode the
last video was episode 104 angular CLI
basics tutorial its description goes
like this master the basics of the
angular v6 CLI the google assistant
makes it easy for users to get things
done in your app through conversation in
today's episode we'll build a Google
assistant app from scratch using
dialogue flow and firebase cloud
functions if you're new here make sure
to LIKE and subscribe and you can grab
the source code at angular firebase comm
let's get started by breaking down the
demo that I just showed you the first
thing that I said was hey Google let's
talk to my app name the app name is
something that you register as the
developer and it signifies the main
entry point into your assistant app when
Google finds this app it's going to
start a session and dialogue flow we've
used dialogue flow before in episode 58
to build a chat bot and it's basically
just a high-level tool for building
conversational experiences it uses some
crazy machine learning algorithms to
handle the natural language processing
so when I say get the latest episode it
knows that I'm trying to convey this get
latest episode intent which in turn is
fulfilled by a firebase cloud function
that goes out and visits the website
gets the information that we need and
then tells the assistant what to say to
the end user and you can even use a rich
card as the response so the user can
just link directly back to your
progressive web app that they already
have installed on their device now that
we know how the basic process works
let's start building our Google
assistant app there are several
different ways we can do this but let's
start in the Google Actions console you
can link your assistant to an existing
firebase or a Google cloud project or
you can just create a new one from
scratch from there you'll select a
category and then the first thing you'll
do is determine the entry point for this
app this parts pretty important because
it's what the user will say to invoke
your app for example hey Google let's
talk to angular firebase com
at this point you could continue
building your app
the actions console and there's a few
templates for doing so but in most cases
you want to switch over to dialogue flow
at this point and start building the
conversation interface click on actions
then add your first action and then
click build go ahead and create the
agent and then switch over to the intent
screen you'll have a default welcome
intent which will greet your user when
they first initiate your app you can
customize the response as needed
but we're going to create a brand new
intent this one's called learn about
angular firebase there are two basic
ways to handle intense the easiest way
is just to create a text response here
in dialog flow which we'll do for this
intent or you can invoke a firebase
cloud function to reach out to the
outside world to retrieve dynamic data
but first we need to get the bot some
training phrases so it knows how to
detect the intent for example what is
angular firebase dialogue flow will use
these phrases to refine the machine
learning algorithm that's used to detect
similar phrases that are said by the
end-user the only other thing you need
at this point is to send the response
back to the user which we can do with
just plain text so when this intent is
triggered it's going to respond to the
user with whatever you put in this text
response and you can add multiple
responses to to give some variation to
your bot so that's the most basic use
case but we want to do something a
little more advanced we want to use a
cloud function to go out to the angular
firebase website and figure out what the
last episode was for that will create a
new intent and then we'll add the
training phrases just like we did before
but this time instead of sending a text
response we're going to flip the switch
for webhook fulfillment this tells
dialogue flow to send some data to our
back-end cloud function then we can use
the dialogue flow SDK for nodejs to
handle these intents and respond back to
the user this makes it possible for your
bot to do things like updated database
reach out to third party API is send
email or anything else you might do in a
node.js back-end you can code your web
hook directly in the browser if you want
to but personally I wouldn't recommend
doing that a better way to do it is to
open up your favorite IDE and then from
the command line run firebase and knit
functions then I highly recommend
using the typescript option and then for
everything else you can just go through
with the main defaults then CD into the
functions directory and install the
actions on Google SDK this will help us
format the responses that go back to
dialog flow so we can build this app
with minimal code then for this project
I'm going to install two other
dependencies that we'll use to build a
simple web scraper which I'll explain in
more detail later for right now just
install node fetch and cheerio then
we'll write all of the code in the index
ts file first we'll import our
dependencies then we can import dialogue
flow from the actions on Google SDK it
also includes a bunch of helpers for
formatting rich cards that you send in
the response for example that card that
would link us back to our progressive
web app then the app itself is very
similar conceptually to Express j/s you
can think of each intent like an HTTP
endpoint that we need to handle whenever
it gets triggered we can say app intent
with get latest episode and then this
will take a callback function to handle
the intent and because we're fetching
data from the outside world
asynchronously will make this an async
function for right now I'm setting up a
placeholder variable called data which
will eventually scrape the web for the
data that we want on angular firebase
comm eventually it will return a title
description and episode number for the
bot to use we can then say conversation
closed or conversation asked to continue
the conversation with the user if you
use ask it's going to keep the
conversation open if you use closed it
will end the dialogue flow session after
that response is sent in this case our
body has nothing else to do so we're
going to use conversation close you
could just pass in a string here but I
think it's easier to use a simple
response which allows you to control
both the text and the speech that the
bot will return so the text will be nice
and concise and then the speech will
contain additional information such as
the full episode description so that's
great for text and speech only
applications but things like smartphones
can handle more than just text and
speech in this case we can send back a
card that will D point to our app and
take the user exactly where they want to
go this works great for both progressive
web apps and native mobile apps
and it's just a great way to build
engagement with your users and that's
pretty much all there is to it on the
dialog flow side the only missing piece
at this point is how do we get this
actual information from the website I'm
not going to talk about this code in
detail because it has nothing to do with
the assistant but all it's doing is
fetching the webpage and then using
cheerio to traverse the DOM to find the
information that we need it's just a
classic web scraper first we need to
fetch the page asynchronously then on
this particular web page we have a feed
of lessons so we want to pull the first
lesson from the page along with its
content then we can extract the text
that is contained within the various
elements inside this div then we'll
return everything is a plain JavaScript
object so we can use it in method that
we had defined earlier to handle the
intent the final step is to export our
function which we'll name fullfillment
it needs to be an HTTP function and it
will take the dialogue flow app as its
argument now open up another command
line terminal and run firebase deploy
only functions when that's finished you
can go to the firebase console and
verify that it's been deployed in the
functions tab and grab the URL endpoint
then switch back over to the fulfillment
tab and dialogue flow and paste it as
the web hook fulfillment URL and that's
pretty much all there is to it you've
now successfully built your own Google
assistant app go back to the actions on
Google console and test it out you can
also test it out on any device that's
connected to your Gmail account that
means you can start testing it out right
away on your Android or iPhone device or
on your Google home device but to
release it to the public you'll go
through a very similar process to the
Google Play Store for Android apps where
you have an alpha beta and then
production release once it's ready to go
wide overall this technology is super
exciting and there's tons of
opportunities for business to engage
their customers in ways that weren't
possible before the demand for
conversation apps is growing rapidly so
it's something you definitely want to be
aware of and familiar with as a
developer I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
have any questions reach out to me on
slack and if you're ready to go beyond
the basics consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase com to get
access to exclusive content
designed to help you build and ship your
app faster thanks for watching and I'll
see you soon